well joining us now from central London
is the government security minister
Brandon Lewis thank you for being with
us today and I just want to start with
the arrest of Britain's ambassador to
Iran we've had a strongly-worded
statement from the Foreign Secretary but
is Britain gonna do anything else yes
well as Dominic Rob rightly outlined
this morning there's a choice for a
round to make and we hope that they will
step out from the edge and want to be
part of the international work to make
sure that we're working globally to get
that chance to de-escalate the whole
situation there but we're calling on
Iran to change course but are we going
to do anything in response to this
arrest I mean is for example pulling the
embassy out of Iran off the table and
we're looking at staffing there what's
happening well obviously we want to make
sure that we have got an ability to talk
to our partners in two countries around
the world so that diplomatic reach that
we having countries all over the world
including around is important for us the
Prime Minister has spoken to President
rouhani just this week we want to make
sure we continue to pay our part in
talking to Iran and our partners around
how we can deescalate matters so
although obviously one of our priorities
is always around the safety and security
of our own teams we also want to make
sure we're able to play our part and
that does mean that we are saying to
Iran to be part of that process
deescalate the situation in Iran and
play a part in the global international
world and you talk though about talking
about trying to de-escalate tensions at
the same time you know this comes this
move from Iran comes after weeks of
escalating tensions between the u.s. and
Iran the u.s. obviously doesn't have an
embassy presence in the country and is a
much bigger power than ours Don Trump's
acted much more aggressively than we
have are we being targeted here because
we're effectively seen as a soft target
well as the for Sochi said we believe
that the actions yesterday with the
Ambassador were breach of the Vienna
Convention the totally unacceptable UN
does need to step back from that kind of
activity and play a proper part in
working with partners to Desco I think
we as a country do have a part to play
working with our partners not just the
USA but the prime minister's been
talking to Angela Merkel
president macron as well to play our
part in trying to de-escalate the
situation which in the long run is in
the best interest of everybody all
around the world and certainly in that
region you say it's unacceptable but it
doesn't sound like we're actually gonna
do anything well you'll understand that
as the security ministry as the
government it would be inappropriate for
me to comment on the work we are doing
more generally around that area and some
of the specific work we're doing to play
our part we do think that was
unacceptable you saw the statement as
you've outlined from Dominic Raab but at
the moment our focus I have to say is on
doing what we can to play our part in
de-escalating the situation because
that's what's in the best interest lot
of people hearing just in the UK but as
I say people in the region and actually
people around the world we want to see
this situation deescalate and people get
back to having a proper conversation and
not least of all playing all of our
parts in that new nuclear deal that we
have and want to keep with Iran and it
comes of course after Iran admitted
responsibility for shooting down that
Ukrainian air line causing the deaths of
176 people including some British
nationals do you find the Iranian
explanation plausible that they
effectively mistook this aircraft for an
incoming cruise missile well also use a
horrendously tragic situational Sakhalin
any loss of life let alone on that kind
of scale and firstly I would say as
others have all our thoughts go out to
all the family of friends of those
victims of us will be suffering in the
moment and it easy important with the
proper respect we get that repatriation
of remains for people to be able to pay
their respects we in terms of the terms
of the structure of what actually
happened there has to be a full clear
transparent investigation as president
Trudeau promised to toe and self outline
that connect haneda wants to play its
part in that countries around the world
and want to see that there is a proper
clear transparent investigation to get
to the bottom of exactly what happened
so that globally and obviously for Iran
itself to make sure or nothing like this
could ever happen again it is completely
unacceptable but - I don't want to get
into prejudging what may the specifics
of what may have happened that's why
it's so important that we all continue
to ensure that there is a proper
transparent investigation